bueno coincido con mi compañera el
terrorismo tiene como función básica
generar miedo y generar terror o sembrar
miedo y sembrar terror es decir generar
una estabilidad económica política y
social durante los últimos 10 15 años ha
habido una continua presencia de
islamismo radical que ha ido de los
cristianos católicos o no eran minoría
se establecía una persecución permitida
o tolerada por las fuerzas policiales
incluso por los gobiernos vemos en la
conversación del ex ministro malayo en
este caso en francia que es el país
laico por osea no no aconfesional si un
laico por definición por sistema
centralista establece que toda persona
que tiene una religión no puede hacer
una licitación pública de ella en un
espacio público eso implica que los
islamistas radicales ven a francia ya
los modelos como los de francia como
lugares a los que derrumbar a los que
atacar y es algo algo que lleva ya
padeciendo muchísimos años
no desde ahora desde la famosa cruzada
del da es contra occidente y desde hace
muchísimos años francia es un polo de
atracción para radicalización puesto que
es o fue un polo también de colonización
en este caso en áfrica o en otros países
en este caso concreto en la regresión
del tunecino y nos hace llevar a cabo un
análisis histórico de lo que ha sido la
recluta islamista en los diversos
territorios y vemos que a pesar de ser
touré con un país que era muy tolerante
antes de todas las primaveras árabes es
el origen de grandes masas o mucha gente
que se afilió tanto al danés como al
qaeda o mcvey y ahora también en francia
ha sido un inmigrante de origen tunecino
el que ha generado este atentado como
bien dice mi compañera no hay un hilo
conductor claro pero si hay un clima
social de este caso un clima islámico en
el que el terrorismo islámico en el que
si se busca cómo poder hacer daño de
manera aislada
al pensamiento francés y al pensamiento
laico cómo es ese pensamiento ese
pensamiento es un riesgo un riesgo desde
el punto de vista educativo el punto de
vista social pero también de poderes de
económico lo que intentan los islamistas
radicales intenta cualquier terrorista
es siempre o bien desestabilizar el
estado o bien subvertirlo y ponerse en
su lugar esta segunda parte es imposible
por tanto lo que intentan es conseguir
que francia eleve el nivel de alerta
eleve el nivel de presión sobre los
musulmanes y así generar mayor tendencia
al islamismo radical por parte de los
islam los musulmanes en francia tenemos
diciendo que es una lástima pero me temo
mucho me temo que vamos a seguir viendo
atentados no sólo en francia y en otros
países porque vuelvo otra vez a ver una
oleada bastante importante de
estabilización